quel que soit le résultat de demain soir
la brillante saison européenne des
bordelais va donc permettre à quelques
joueurs de partir vers de grands clubs
européens parmi eux le plus recherché
sans aucun doute jean eddine zidane 23
ans en italie notamment à la juventus de
turin qui s'intéresse de très près à lui
on l'appelle déjà elle nouveau platini
florent gautreau christophe vidal à
bordeaux personne ne l'appelle zinedine
zidane mais zizou un surnom trouvé par
rolland courbis l'ancien entraîneur du
club
sylla n'a toujours su se faire apprécier
et quand il jouait à cannes un
entraîneur l'avait déjà remarqué quand
je prenais souvent écran dans la voiture
c'est le ramener sous employés là où il
était avec les jeunes du centre de
formation et salaires sans qu'il ya de
ce côté là qui a qui a su rester
rebondir avec beaucoup de simplicité les
rester gentil il était très abordable et
ça c'est la 3è voir un grand de 23 ans
qui a terminé sa croissance aux
girondins depuis 92 très grand mais très
modeste zidane s'étonne presque d'être
aujourd'hui le joueur le plus convoité
de francs je rêvais même pas du tout
ce n'est professionnel je crois que
c'était c'était je suis parti à cannes
comme ça pour pour port et ses deux
bambins de jouer au ballon de faire
aussi mes études parce que j'étais pas
seulement parce qu'on est au football on
ne sait jamais aimé jacquet il dit c'est
qu'il a trouvé la perle rare en 9 94
pour sa première sélection en équipe de
france contre la république tchèque
il entre en jeu à vingt minutes de la
fin et marc deux bus on peut la france
arrachent le nul et le public découvre
un joueur techniquement au dessus de la
moyenne pour montrer qu'il sait tout
faire avec un ballon
tout le monde sait qu'il est capable
d'éliminer n'importe qui dans la
rencontre
c'est aussi jouer à une touche de balle
une sèche surtout se met au service de
l'équipe au service de l'équipe et
notamment de christophe dugarry compote
je suis très bien avec lui et c'est sa
monarchie est un rigolo c'est cette
rousse allemands vivent partout au
contraire parce que parce que j'aime
bien aussi
pas de dire que je suis une poignée à me
renfermer entre eux je suis simplement
un timide et zizou les timides fait
toujours parler lui les joueurs français
l'ont élu meilleur footballeur de
l'année l'année zidane peut-être ans est
montée du meilleur footballeur de
l'année l'année zidane peut-être